what are the right ways and wrong ways
to introduce a main character I said
earlier that you know backstory isn't
always story
so if you are slavishly devoted to
spelling out everything that's happened
to a person up to the point that you
meet them for the first time
it's a huge drag it's like you've
saddled them with a weight that is so
heavy like the explanation of themselves
that you can't just invest in whatever
moment you're introduced to them in
you know like if you watch a Bond film
and you've never seen the James Bond
film before and the first shot you see
is this guy jumping out of the
helicopter on a parachute and they were
like I bet you're wondering how I got
here well my name is James and I went to
school here and this happened and then
one day same somebody came up to me and
said do you want to be in a high school
program for secret agent wannabes and I
said sure and it was okay but it took a
long time and I wasn't really good with
a gun at first but now I'm amazing I
have a license to Kill
and then the parachute comes back to you
would hate that
so this whole thing about you know
backstory and knowing everything about
somebody before you see them
is is a is not a great way to introduce
a character
introducing a character during a moment
in which they are vulnerable is
immediately engaging
look at shows like or look at movies
like Diary of a Wimpy Kid
I'm trying to think of an example that I
would give you myself but I don't have
one that immediately comes to mind I'm
47 shows and several hundred episodes in
I don't remember them all
sometimes I watch TV and I go I forgot I
worked on that it's very rare but it
does happen
thanks for reruns of shows I did 15
years ago that somebody said we'll never
be able to re-air it because there's no
aftermarket for reality shows and that's
why you can't have portable pension and
health through the writer's Guild
because we don't want to pay for
something we can only air one time then
they run a marathon of it every Saturday
for a year and a half
but I'll keep my personal wounds out of
this because that's all backstory
what is a character's flaw and why is it
important for us to know that in the
story
the character flaw
often is just is something to help you
as the viewer identify with a character
that's why we have them I'm not perfect
so I don't want to watch people who are
perfect
uh when you watch movies like Clueless
where you watch movies like Mean Girls
you get to see what's wrong with every
character and the other thing the
character flaw does is it allows you to
project onto them imperfect people that
you already know in your life and you go
oh that's like so and so that's like the
person who used to talk about me all the
time in high school and I always wished
something would happen to them
you know somebody would confiscate their
burn book
it's real character for character flaws
make characters identifiable to the
laymen who are watching the film
what if somebody's too flawed in a movie
if they're too flawed in the movie to a
point where I can't root for them
uh that is a problem
and
I'm trying to think of a good example
if you watch if you watch a movie where
somebody is so relentlessly crap at
everything they do
you're not excited for them you don't
root for them anymore like Clouseau
the thing in the The Pink Panther films
that works with him is
he is a bumbling idiot
but he has regard for himself
and he wants to be seen as very
successful that we can all identify with
and that overtakes the flaw
so you you realize that this is a person
who can fail if you don't think someone
can fail you can't identify with them
and there are no stakes in place for
them
during that film is a person who is
nothing but a string of successes what a
snooze
like you know even in in a Bond film
every once in a while somebody gets away
on their little glider or whatever and
you're like well he's gonna get him the
next time he's not gonna get him this
time he's escaped so now we've got three
more movies to watch to see if he ever
gets to that guy
what's your favorite flawed character
oh man
there are there are there are so many
I think Peter Sellers as Clouseau is
pretty good
um Chance The Gardener who in being
there who also was played by Peter
Sellers is a flawed character who is
just not particularly mentally with it
and he keeps stumbling through these
situations that he somehow
not only survives but turns to his own
benefit Without Really Trying
um
it's a lot of outside forces on the
character which is also something I
don't normally like but he's so likable
as someone who is just trying to get
through and be emotionally sensitive and
involved with the people around him
that that kind of that kind of wipes
away every everything
I think you just identify them because
you know what it's like to be in a
situation where you can't control what's
happening
so you can still identify with them even
though he's not mentally very with it
why is it important for the main
character to have transformation because
if nothing changes
what did you just watch
how can you not be affected by an hour
and a half or two hours worth of things
happening to you
transformation is important because we
also you know we ourselves hopefully as
life progresses I am not the same person
I was at 10.
thank God what a nervous little runt I
was
wanting to be somebody notable
you know no 12 year old should be
talking to his friends about his legacy
like what am I leaving behind what will
people remember me for
and who cares
I did but I mean like that was that was
a pretty big flaw like I'm not a big fan
of younger me
the younger me was afraid of everything
because everything I did was an
opportunity for me to humiliate myself
in front of my peers I wanted to be a
cartoonist
or a comic book artist which nobody I
knew wanted to be or wanted to do and
because it was a different interest I
couldn't find common ground with him on
it so I was just the weirdo who was
always drawing in class who in middle
school was having his drawings stuck on
the wall in the back of the classroom by
my homeroom teacher like I was five
it was just a very strange
place to be
what are the biggest mistakes you see
writers make with their main characters
uh they don't think about them or they
are trying to write to an archetype
that they're they're not creating a
fully rounded character they're just
they're creating a hero that could be
interchangeable with any other hero from
any other film
what are some of these archetypes
um well the superhero the secret agent
you know the ones that seem to be
basically the same in every movie
these you know these infallible folks or
somebody who's completely based on
another character
and that happens a lot like I remember
when Tarantino movies first became a big
thing
I read a lot of screenplays that my
friends had worked on that were just
these very long talky things
and just the most important thing was
that somebody said
you know every five minutes
or three minutes or two minutes or 30
seconds
and they were just trying to emulate uh
what they had seen other writers write
the main characters weren't individual
they weren't personal to the writer
they weren't identifiable as actual
people
is their their toys that are being made
to follow a routine for this purpose of
writing a screenplay that feels like
something else that someone else had
seen
do you think that was just a trend the
way you know people try to emulate found
footage horrible films people do it all
the time I mean anything that's
successful becomes the thing that you
try to emulate and I remember when I was
younger I used to oh man I was trying to
write Woody Allen movies
and every character I had was some poor
schlubby little Underdog that was with
somebody who was way too pretty for them
and was always worried that his world
was going to collapse at any minute
because the pretty girl was going to
figure out that he was nobody
that was a lot of my own insecurity
because like Woody Allen films were very
close to me when I was younger because I
just was so into at a very young age it
was like
this is what life is really like for
most people it's this is a guy who's
successful on a certain level but he
never thinks that he's ever won
you know he's not he's not necessarily
an underdog all the time
but he is also not uh not a particularly
confident lead and I like that because I
didn't I didn't feel like I was
hot stuff when I was started writing
do you think that he he was the voice
for what most people think but they just
didn't want to give the appearance that
they didn't have it figured out and that
thing yeah and there's that great moment
in in Annie Hall where he's standing in
line for a movie and some bloviating
jerk is talking about the film
and he says oh well I I don't think
you're right I mean he says oh well
let's ask Marshall mcluhan and he pulls
in like one of the greatest media
scholars in the history at the time to
debate this guy in the lobby of a movie
theater
about was I was it Triumph of the will
was the movie that he had dragged her to
go see forgotten sorry it's been a long
time to see some Lenny riefenstall film
and this guy was talking about
just pulling stuff out of nowhere trying
to make himself sound educated and just
pulled this guy over he's like well
Marshall let's ask Marshall McClellan
about that I don't think half of the
people that watched the movie knew who
Marshall mcluhan was
but it's you know
it's fun it's a little Easter egg for
intellectuals to be like oh cool